President Trump gave yet another
unhinged performance
at a campaign rally on Saturday.
And his education secretary
followed up the next day
by giving a train wreck of
an interview to "60 Minutes."
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
With the Stormy Daniels story
gaining traction every day
and the Russia investigation
intensifying,
maybe Trump is under
an unusual amount of stress
because on Saturday, he flew
to Pennsylvania to rally for
the Republican candidate in a
special Congressional election,
and even by his standards,
Trump's antics were especially
off the rails.
Now, as for the candidate,
Rick Saccone,
who Trump was ostensibly there
to support, he barely came up.
Trump's like the friend
you invite
to your karaoke birthday party
who shows up late,
doesn't bring a gift,
and then sings
"Stairway to Heaven"
10 times in a row.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump was playing
all the hits,
reeling off vulgar insults
of reporters and politicians
by name, like, for example,
when he brought up the prospect
of running against Oprah
and implied that he knew
something about her
that the public does not.
-Wouldn't we love to run
against Oprah?
I would love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That would be a painful
experience for her.
Oh, I'd love Oprah to win.
I'd love to beat Oprah.
I know her weakness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, I know her weakness.
-I know her weakness?
[ Laughter ]
He talks about Oprah the way
Lex Luthor talks about Superman.
[ Laughter ]
And you're not special.
We all know her weakness.
-I love bread.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And listen,
don't think you can stop her
just because you look like
the Pillsbury Doughboy.
[ Laughter ]
And that's it.
That's Oprah's only weakness.
This is a woman who spent
30 years getting celebrities
to cry on television.
She broke Lance Armstrong.
If Trump ever does debate Oprah,
there's a good chance
it will end
with him sobbing at the podium.
[ As Trump ] "You know, you know
who I wish they'd lock up?
The part of me that's sad."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] But, of course,
Trump was not merely content
to attack one black woman
in his rant.
He then went after California
congresswoman Maxine Waters
specifically by insulting
her intelligence.
-We have to defeat Nancy Pelosi.
[ Crowd boos ]
And Maxine Waters,
a very low I.Q. Individual.
-I don't know.
I bet she says "I.Q." faster.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] "I...Q."
[ Normal voice ]
And Trump knows --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys, Trump knows
high I.Q. individuals,
like his Secretary of Education
Betsy DeVos,
seen here crushing it last night
on "60 Minutes."
-Have the public schools
in Michigan gotten better?
-I don't know. Overall,
I can't say overall that
they have all gotten better.
-Your argument that if you
take funds away,
that the schools will get better
is not working in Michigan.
Where you have a huge impact
and influence over the direction
of the school system here.
-I hesitate to talk about
all schools in general
because schools are made up
of individual students
attending them.
-Have you seen
the really bad schools?
Maybe try to figure out what --
what they're doing?
-I have not. I have not.
I've not intentionally
visited schools
that are underperforming.
-Maybe you should.
-Maybe I should.
-F-minus. F-minus.
She's the highest ranking
education official
in the country, and she acts
like a substitute teacher
who is just realizing her U.S.
history isn't up to speed.
[ Laughter ]
"Can anyone tell me what this
is a picture of?"
"Yeah, it's George Washington
crossing the Delaware."
"Well, no, because Delaware
is a state.
[ Laughter ]
So you wouldn't need a boat
to cross it."
"Yeah, it's also a river."
"I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, it is.
Maybe you should look it up."
"Yeah. Maybe I should."
[ Laughter ]
Now Trump always --
[ Applause ]
Trump always insults
and degrades people
at these rallies.
But his performance on Saturday
was especially manic and vulgar.
For example, Trump started
ranting about his decision
to meet with North Korean leader
Kim Jong-un.
And when referencing an
interview he gave years ago
on "Meet the Press" said this
about host Chuck Todd.
-It's 1999.
I'm on "Meet the Press,"
a show now headed
by Sleepy Eyes Chuck Todd.
He's a sleeping son of a bitch,
I'll tell you.
-You're calling Chuck Todd
a son of a bitch?
Seriously, you know someone's
not a son of a bitch
when they still come off
as approachable
despite having the exact same
facial hair as Evil Spock.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is, of course, so obsessed
with earning the praise
and validation of the media,
that at one point during
his rant on North Korea,
he literally just started
rambling nonsensically
about President Obama,
claiming Obama would not have
been able to arrange a meeting
with Kim Jong-un.
-They're saying not
that big a deal,
anybody could have done it.
Obama could have done it.
Obama had a chance --
[ Crowd boos ]
No, no. They're saying -- Obama.
Obama. Obama.
-Just --
[ Laughter ]
Just mumbling Obama's name
like --
like Obama was the name
of his childhood sled.
[ Laughter ]
His presidential diaries
are going to look like
the manuscript
from "The Shining."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, one major difference
between Obama and Trump
is that for Trump the presidency
isn't actually a job,
it's just a performance.
And on Saturday, he defended
his performance by playing
make-believe onstage
and acting out
what it would be like
if he were less unhinged
and more subdued as president.
-You know how easy -- remember
I used to say how easy it is
to be presidential?
But you'd all be out of here
right now if I --
you'd be so bored.
Because I could stand up, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm very presidential.
[ Deep voice ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for being here
tonight.
And then you go, "God bless you,
and God bless the United States
of America."
Thank you very much.
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
-I have to say, he might be
the only white comedian
who does a white guy voice.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's pretty [bleep] funny
sometimes.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's ranting about
North Korea
and being presidential
tells us a lot
about his shock announcement
last week that he had agreed
to a summit meeting
with Kim Jong-un.
Now it's undeniably better
to be on a path toward peace
than a ramp-up to war.
And if Trump somehow manages
to fall ass-backwards
into a peaceful resolution
with North Korea,
then that is absolutely
a good thing.
And if that happens,
I will be the first to admit,
okay, he wasn't Darth Vader,
he was Mr. Bean.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But for Trump, this is as usual
mostly about the show,
not about the policy because
for months,
he's repeatedly insisted that
diplomacy was not the answer
and even as late as last week,
he was incredibly vague
about whether he favored
negotiation or military action.
-President Trump tweeted,
and I quote...
-We sent out through social
media statement
willing to go either way.
Hopefully it's going to be
the proper way.
The proper way is the way
that everybody knows
and everybody wants.
-Wow. You are so clear
and well spoken.
Who was your teacher?
Betsy DeVos?
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Trump kept --
kept batting down
his own Secretary of State's
attempts to secure
a peaceful resolution
even when asked point blank
what he would do was incredibly
vague because, of course,
he had no idea what he would do.
It was only after
careful diplomacy
that South Korea was able
to make this breakthrough,
Trump caring only about the
spectacle accepted on the spot,
while Congressional leaders
and top officials
at the Pentagon
and State Department
learned what was happening
from news reports.
So the Pentagon
and State Department
have to watch the news to find
out what the President is doing.
I guess it's not surprising
since the President
also watches the news to find
out what the President's doing.
[ Applause ]
In fact, even --
even the way Trump notified
the press about the news
was more about theater
than substance.
After the South Koreans
relayed the invitation,
Trump walked over
to the White House briefing room
and teased reporters with
a vague announcement.
-Within the last few moments,
President Trump stuck his head
into the White House
briefing room and said that
there would be a major
announcement
coming this evening.
-And I said, "Mr. President,
what is the announcement
going to be on?"
And he said, "North Korea."
-We're showing our viewers
a picture when he simply walked
into the briefing room over
there, the press briefing room.
-Okay, first of all,
you can't just pop in,
say you've got big news
on North Korea, and leave.
That's like your doctor
peeking into your exam room
and saying, "I just
got your test results back,
and they are crazy!"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, though, look at him.
He looks like he's popping
his head into the break room
to see if there's
any pizza left.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] "You guys,
big news on North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
You guys eat all the pizza?"
[ Normal voice ] But Trump
made his priorities clear
when he spoke to reporters
Thursday.
He didn't comment
on the substance
of the announcement
or how it would work.
His focus was mainly about how
the press would report on it.
-He was almost giddy about this,
ecstatic about this news.
He said that this
would be a big development.
I asked if it was about
negotiations.
He said says it's almost
beyond that and then he said,
"I hope you give me credit."
-That's all he cares about.
He just wants credit
unless things go wrong,
then he wants to avoid blame.
If he meets with Kim Jong-un
and it's a disaster,
you know who who
he'll blame it on.
-Obama. Obama. Obama.
-So the President is ranting
nonsensically at rallies
and his Education Secretary
is giving incomprehensible
answers about education,
all while the White House
tries to resolve
a tense situation
with North Korea.
If Trump manages to stumble
his way into
a diplomatic breakthrough,
that would undoubtedly
be a great thing.
But if that happens,
he will have done it
despite being a very...
-Low I.Q. individual.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪